ils sont prêts à mener leur embuscade
leur cible c'est passager de la ligne
468 n'ai pas d'inquiétude cette
embuscade fait partie du printemps des
poètes
il vous la peine d'être vécue même si
elle est détesté la vie vaut la peine
d'être vécue même si elle est méprisé la
vie vaut la peine d'être vécue même si
elle est humiliée ce printemps ce
printemps c'est le terme poèmes
d'afrique et d'ailleurs donc on a failli
tout une collection des problèmes qui
ont touché notre coeur qui nous ont
inspirés qui nous a
donner envie de partager donc ça c'est
les poètes africains de tout type
d'afrique du nord les chu de est ouest
est d'ailleurs aussi était-il ses
comédiens ne sont pas là par hasard
ils ont la complicité de ski bus c'est
la deuxième année que le réseau les
accueils sur si l'une la vie on a
imaginé avec jacques fournier d
itinéraire poétique les embuscades
poétique et ski bus avait tenté l'année
dernière de faire cette expérience et
les clients avaient été plutôt
satisfaits et séduit par cette opération
qu'on a voulu renouveler cette année
mais rassurez vous tous les passagers
ont été libérés avec un peu de poésie
dans un coin de la tête chaleur signé
ici le soleil fera place la lune la lune
nuages les nuages à la nuit on voit le
moigne cap au stade j
[Musique]